well I have to ask because Ron Howard
the director asked us on Twitter since
we're talking about the threat of
nuclear war and otherwise he asked I'd
be interested in both your expectations
for Human Society if when we move Beyond
Mars
with those societies be industrial based
how will it be governed how will
criminal infractions be dealt with
when you read or watch Sci-Fi what comes
closest to sounding logical do you think
about our society beyond Earth
if a colonized Mars if a colonized space
yeah well I think I have a pretty
a humbling picture of that so because
we're still going to be the Apes that we
are so we when you when you imagine
colonizing Mars
you have to imagine a first fist fight
on Mars you have to imagine the first
murder on Mars also infidelity yeah
somebody extramarital Affairs on Mars
right so it's gonna get uh really homely
and boring really fast I think you know
it's like only the spacesuits or
whatever the other uh
extendencies of just living in that
atmosphere or lack thereof uh will limit
how badly we can behave on Mars but do
you think most of the interaction will
be still in Meet Space versus digital do
you think there will be do you think
we're like living through a
transformation of a kind
where we're going to be doing more and
more interaction than digital space
like everything we've been complaining
about Twitter
is it possible that Twitter is just the
early days of a broken system that's
actually uh giving birth to a better
working system that's ultimately digital
I think we're gonna
experience a pendulum swing back into
the real world I mean I think many of us
are experiencing that now anyway I mean
just just wanting to
have face to face encounters and spend
less time on our phones and less time
online I think uh you know maybe
everyone isn't going in that direction
but
I do notice it myself and I notice
I mean once I got off Twitter then I
noticed the people who were never on
Twitter right and then and the people
who are never basically I mean I know I
have a lot of friends who are never on
Twitter yeah and they actually never
understood what I was doing on Twitter
it's like like they just like it wasn't
that they were seeing it and then
reacting to it they just didn't know
it's like
it's like being on riff like I'm not on
Reddit either but I don't spend any time
thinking about not being on Reddit right
it's like I just I'm just not on Reddit
um so you think the pursuit of human
happiness is better achieved more
effectively achieved outside of
Twitter world
well I I think all we have is our
attention in the end and we just have to
notice what these various tools are
doing to it and
it's just it became very clear to me
that
it was an unrewarding use of my
attention now it's not to say there
isn't some digital platform that's
conceivable that would be
useful but
um and rewarding but
yeah I mean we just have you know our
life is doled out to us in moments and
we we have and we're continually solving
this riddle of
what is going to suffice to make this
moment engaging and meaningful and
aligned with
who I want to be now and how I want the
future to to look right we're all in
this that we have this tension between
being in the present and becoming in the
future
and um
you know it's a seeming Paradox again
it's not really a paradox but it can see
like I do think the ground truth
for personal well-being
is to find a mode of being where
you can pay attention
to the present moment and this is you
know meditation by another name
you can pay attention to the present
moment with sufficient you know gravity
that you recognize that that just
Consciousness itself in the present
moment no matter what's happening is
already a circumstance of freedom and
and contentment and and Tranquility like
you can be happy now before anything
happens before this next desire gets
gratified before this next problem gets
solved there's a there's this kind of
ground truth that that you're free that
Consciousness is free and open and
unencumbered by really any problem until
you get lost and thought about all the
problems that may yet be real for you so
the ability to catch and observe
Consciousness that in itself is a source
of Happiness without being lost in
thought and so what what this happened
this happens
haphazardly for people who don't
meditate because they find something in
their life that's so captivating
it's so pleasurable it's so thrilling it
can even be scary but it can be even
being scared is captivated like so it
gets it gets their attention right
whatever it is if you like you know
Sebastian younger or you know was wrote
a great book about
people's experience in war here you know
it's like like you can strangely it can
be the best experience anyone's ever had
because everything it's like only the
moment matters right like the the bullet
is whizzing by your head you're not
thinking about your your 401k or that
thing that you didn't say last week to
the person you shouldn't have been
talking about you're not thinking about
Twitter it's like you're just
fully immersed in the present moment
um
meditation is the only way I mean the
the that word can mean many things to
many people but what I mean by
meditation is simply the discovery that
there is a a
a way to
engage the present moment directly
regardless of what's Happening you don't
need to be in a war you don't need to be
having sex you don't need to be on drugs
you don't need to be surfing you don't
need nothing there doesn't have to be a
peak experience it can be completely
ordinary but you can recognize that in
some basic sense there's only this and
and everything else is something you're
thinking you're thinking about the past
you're thinking about the future and
thoughts themselves have no substance
right it's it's fundamentally mysterious
that any thought
ever really commandeers your sense of
who you are and and makes you anxious or
afraid or or angry or whatever it is
um and the more you discover that the
half-life of all these negative emotions
that blow all of us around
get much much shorter right and you can
you can literally just
you know the the anger that would have
kept you angry for hours or days
lasts you know four seconds because you
just the moment it arises you recognize
it and you can get off that you can
decide at minimum you can decide whether
it's useful to stay angry at that moment
and you know obviously it usually isn't
and the illusion of Free Will is one of
those thoughts yeah it's all just
happening right like even the Mindful
and meditative response to this is just
happening and happening it's just like
even
the moments where you recognize or not
recognize is just happening it's not
that the the
this does open up a degree of freedom
for a person but it's not a freedom that
gives any motivation to the notion of
free will it's just a new
way of being in the world is there a
difference between intellectually
knowing Free Will as an illusion and
really experiencing it yeah what's the
what's the longest you've been able to
experience the escape the illusion if
you will well it's always I it's always
obvious to me when I pay attention I
mean when I whenever I'm mindful there's
a the term of jargon you know in the
Buddhist and and increasingly you know
outside the Buddhist context is is
mindfulness right but there are sort of
different levels of mindfulness and
there's there's different um
degrees of insight into this but yes I
mean what I'm calling evidence of lack
of Free Will and lack of you know lack
of the self and I got two sides of the
same coin there's a sense of being
a subject in the middle of experience to
whom all experience refers the sense of
I the sense of me
and that's almost everybody's starting
point when they they start to meditate
and that's almost always the place
people live most of their lives from I
do think that gets interrupted in ways
that get unrecognized I think people are
constantly losing the sense of I they're
losing the sense of subject object
distance
but they're not recognizing it and and
meditation is
the mode in which you can recognize you
can you can both consciously precipitate
it you can look for the self and fail to
find it and then recognize its absence
and that's the just the flip side of the
coin of free will I mean the the the
feeling of having free will is what it
feels like to feel like a self
who's thinking his thoughts and doing
his actions and intending his intentions
and he the the man in the middle of the
boat who's Rowan
um
that's the story that's the false
starting point when you find that
there's no one in the middle of the boat
right or in fact there's no boat there's
just the river there's just the flow of
experience
and there's no Center to it and there's
no place from which you would control it
again even when you're doing things this
does not negate the difference between
voluntary and involuntary Behavior it's
like
I can voluntarily reach for this but
when I'm paying attention I'm aware that
everything is just happening like just
the intention to move is just a rising
right and
I'm in no position I don't know why I
didn't arise a moment before or a moment
later or a moment or you know
50 stronger or weaker or you know so as
to be ineffective or to be doubly
effective where I lurched for it versus
I moved slow I mean I'm not
I can never run the counter factuals I
can never all this opens the door to a
and even more disconcerting picture
along the same lines which is
subsumes this conversation about Free
Will and it's the question of whether
anything is ever possible like what if
this is a question I I haven't thought a
lot of about it but
it's been a few years I've been kicking
this question around
um
what if only the actual
is possible what it what if there was
what if it was do we live with this
feeling of possibility we live with a
sense that
let me take it so you know I have two
daughters
I could have had a third child right so
what does it mean to say that I could
have had a third child right so do you
you don't have kids I don't think so not
that I know of yes so the possibility
might be there so what do we mean when
we say
you could have had a child or
you might you you might have a child in
the future like what what what is the
space in real what's the relationship
between possibility and actuality and
reality is there a reality in which
non-actual things
are nonetheless real and so there we
have other categories of like non
concrete things we have things that
don't have spatial temporal Dimension
but they're nonetheless they nonetheless
exist so like you know in the integers
right so numbers
there's a there's a reality there's an
abstract reality to numbers and this is
it's philosophically interesting to
think about these things so they're not
like in some sense they're
they're
real
and they're just they're not merely
invented by us they're discovered
because they have structure that we
can't impose upon them right it's not
like they're not fictional characters
like you know I mean Hamlet and Superman
also exist in some sense but they exist
at the level of of Our Own
fiction and abstraction but it's like
they're true they're true and false
statements you can make about Hamlet
they're true and false statements you
can make about Superman because our
fiction the fictional worlds we've
created have a certain kind of structure
but again this is all abstract it's like
it's all abstractable from any of its
concrete instantiations it's not just in
the comic books and just in the movies
it's in our you know ongoing ideas about
these characters
but natural numbers or
um
the integers don't
function quite that way I mean they're
similar but they also have a structure
that's purely a matter of Discovery it's
not you can't just make up whether
numbers are prime
you know if you give me two integers you
know of a certain size to let's you
mentioned two enormous integers
if I were to say okay well between those
two integers they're exactly 11 prime
numbers right that's a very specific
Claim about which I can be right or
wrong and whether or not anyone knows
I'm writers like that's just there's a
domain of facts there these are abstract
it's an abstract reality that relates in
some way that's philosophically
interesting you know metaphysically
interesting too
what we call real reality you know this
the spatial temporal order
the physics of things
but
possibility at least in my view occupies
a different space and this is something
again I my thoughts on this are pretty
in code and I I think I need to talk to
a philosopher of physics and and or
physicist about how this may interact
with with things like the many worlds
interpretation yeah that's an
interesting like right exactly so I I
wonder if discover is in physics like
further proof or more concrete proof
that many was interpretation of quantum
Organics has some validity right if that
completely starts to change things but
even that that's just more
actuality so if I took that seriously ah
sure that's that's the case of
and and Truth is that happens even even
if the many worlds interpretation isn't
true but we just imagine we have a
physically infinite universe
the implication of infinity is such that
things will begin to repeat themselves
you know the farther you go in space
right so the you know if if you just
head out in One Direction eventually
you're going to meet two people just
like us having a conversation just like
this and you're going to meet them an
infinite number of times in every you
know infinite variety of permutations
slightly different from this
conversation right so I mean Infinity is
just so big that our intuitions of
probability completely break down
but what I'm suggesting is
maybe probability isn't a thing right
maybe there's only actuality if there's
maybe there's only what happens
and at every point along the way
our notion of what could have happened
or what might have happened is just that
it's just a thought about what could
have happened or might there's no so
it's a fundamentally different thing if
you can imagine a thing that doesn't
make it real
so they because that's that's where that
possibility exists is in your
imagination right yeah and possibility
itself is a kind of spooky idea because
it it too has a sort of structure
right so like if I if I'm going to say
you know
you could have had a daughter right last
year
um
so we're saying that's that's possible
but not actual
right that is a claim they're things
that
are true and not true about that
daughter right like that it has a kind
of structure it's like
I feel like there's a lot of fog around
that the possibility it feels like
almost like a useful narrative but what
does it mean so like
what does it mean if if we say you know
I just did that but I'm it's conceivable
that I wouldn't have done that right
like it's possible that I I just threw
this cap but I might not have done that
so you're taking it very temporarily
close to the original like what would
appear as a decision
whenever we're saying something's
possible but not actual right like this
thing just happened but it's conceived
it's possible that it wouldn't have
happened or it would have happened
differently
in what does that possibility
consist like where is that what it for
that to be real for the possibility to
be real
what are we what claim are we making
about
the universe well isn't that an
extension of the idea that Free Will is
an illusion that all we have is
sexuality that the possibility isn't
right yeah I'm just extending it Beyond
is this Human Action uh like it's it's
this goes to the physics of things this
is just everything like we're always
telling ourselves a story yeah that
includes possibility possibility is
really compelling for some reason
well yeah well because it's it's
I mean so this yeah I mean this could
sound just academic but it every
backward looking regret or
disappointment and every forward-looking
worry
is completely dependent on this notion
of possibility like every regret is
based on the sense that something else I
could have done something else something
else could have happened every
disposition to worry about the future
is based on the feeling that there's
this range of possibilities it could go
either way
and
you know I I know whether whether or not
there's such a thing as possibility you
know I'm convinced that worry is Almost
Never
psychologically
appropriate because the reality is in
any given moment
either you can do something to solve the
problem you're worried about or not so
if you can do something just do it you
know and if you can't you're worrying is
just causing you to suffer twice over
right you're gonna
you know you're gonna you're gonna get
the medical procedure next week anyway
how much time between now and next week
do you want to spend worrying about it
right it's gonna it's the worry the
worry doesn't accomplish anything how
much do physicists think about
possibility well they think about it in
terms of probability
more often but probability just
describes
and again this is a place where I might
be out of my depth and need to talk to
somebody to to uh debunk this but the um
do therapy with a physicist yeah um but
probably it seems just describes a
pattern of actuality that we've observed
right I mean we have there are certain
things we observe
and those are the actual things that
have happened
and we have this additional story about
probability I mean we have the frequency
with which things happen have happened
in the past
um
you know I can flip a Fair coin and know
I know in the abstract that I have a
belief that in the limit that those
flips those tosses should Converge on 50
heads and 50 Tails I know I have a story
as to why it's not going to be exactly
50 within any
arbitrary time frame
um
but in reality all we ever have are the
observed tosses
right and then we have an additional
story that oh it came up heads but it
could have come up tails
why do we think that
about that last toss
what and and what are we claiming is
true
about the physics of things
if we say it could have been otherwise I
think we're claiming that probability is
true
that that just it allows us to
have a nice model about the world it
gives us hope about the world yeah it
seems that possibility has to be
somewhere to be effective it's a little
it's a little bit like what's what's
happening with the laws there's
something metaphysically interesting
about the laws of nature too because the
laws of nature so the laws of nature
impose their their work on the world
right we see their evidence
but they're not reducible to any
specific set of instances right so
there's some structure there
but the structure isn't
just a matter of the actual things with
the actual billiard balls that are
banging into each other
all of that actuality can be explained
by what actual things are actually doing
but then we have this notion that in
addition to that
we have the laws of nature that are
making they're explaining this activity
but how are the laws of nature an
additional thing
in addition to just the actual things
that are actually effect costly and if
they're if they are an additional thing
in how are they effective if not they're
not among the actual things that are
just actually banging around yeah and so
to some degree for that possible
possibly has to be hiding somewhere for
the laws of nature to be possible
for anything to be possible it has to be
it has to have closets somewhere I'm
sure it's just where all the possibility
goes it has to be attached to something
so you don't think many worlds is that
yeah because Mayweather still exists
well because we're in this strand of
that Multiverse yeah right so it's still
still you have just a local instance of
what is actual yeah and then if it
proliferates elsewhere where you can't
be affected by it many worlds actuality
you can't really connect with the other
yeah yeah and so many worlds is just a
statement of
basically everything that can happen
happens somewhere
right that's yeah you know and that's I
mean maybe that's not an entirely kosher
formulation of it but it it seems pretty
close so so but there's whatever happens
right in fact there's you know
relativistically there's a
there's a you know the the Einstein's
original notion of a block universe
seems to suggest this and I it's been a
while since I've been in a conversation
with a physicist where I've gotten a
chance to ask about the standing of this
concept in physics currently I don't
hear it discuss much but the idea of a
block universe is that you know the
space-time
exists as a totality in our sense that
we are traveling
through space-time
where there's a real difference between
the past and the future
that that's an illusion of just our you
know
you know weird the weird the weird slice
we're taking of of this larger object
but on some level
it's like you know you're reading a
novel The last page of the novel exists
just as much as the first page when
you're in the middle of it and they're
just
you know if that's if we're living in
anything like that then there's no such
thing as
possibility I I would it would seem as
just
what is actual
so
as a matter of our experience moment to
moment
I think it's totally compatible with
that being true that there is only what
is actual and
that sounds to the the naive ear that
sounds like it would be depressing and
disempowering and confining
but it's anything but it's actually it's
a circumstance of pure Discovery like
you have no idea what's going to happen
next right you don't know who you're
going to be tomorrow you're only by
tendency seeming to resemble yourself
from yesterday and there's there's way
more freedom in all of that than than it
seems true to many people and
yet
the basic Insight is that you're not
you're not in the the real freedom is is
the recognition that you're not in
control of anything everything is just
happening including your thoughts and
intentions and moves so life is a is a
process of continuous Discovery you're
part of the universe yeah you are you
are just this I mean it's
it's the miracle that the the universe
is illuminated to itself as itself where
you sit and you're and you're
continually discovering
what your life is
and then you're you have this layer at
which you're telling yourself a story
that you already know what your life is
and you know exactly you know who you
should be and what's you know what's
about to happen or you're struggling to
form a confident opinion about all of
that and yet there is this this
fundamental mystery to everything even
the most familiar experience
we're all NPCs in the most marvelous
video game
maybe although my my game my sense of
gaming is does not run as deep as to
know what I'm committing to there's a
non it's a non-plane character you're
more yeah oh wow yes you're more you're
more of a Mario Kart guy yeah yeah I
went back I was an original video gamer
but it's been a long time since I I mean
I was I was there for pong I remember
when I saw the first pong in a
restaurant in uh
I think it was like Benihana's or
something they had a pong and a table
and that was it amazing it was an
amazing moment when he was you Sam
harrisman I lived from pong
to the invention and deployment of a
super intelligent system yeah well that
that happened fast if it happens anytime
in my lifetime from from pong to AGI